نحن هنا في قسم غسيل الكلى في مستشفى
شهداء الاقصى وهو القسم الوحيد في
المحافظه الوسطى في هذا
المستشفى قليل الامكانيات في الاونه
الاخيره بسبب العدوان الاسرائيلي والحرب
المستمره على قطاع غزه هذا القسم كان قبل
الحرب مباشره يستقبل في اليوم 160 مريض
غسيل كلا ولكن في ايام الحرب يستقبل ما
يقارب من
450 مواطن غسيل كلاه بالاضافه الى ذلك
هناك اداد من ساعات غسيل الكلى يتم
تقليصها وبشكل كبير بسبب الازدحام الكبير
في داخل القسم وببب ايضا المواطنين الذين
ياتوا من شمال قطع غزه ومن مدينه غزه خلال
الايام الاخيره انا نازحه من خانيونس
لما اتحم خانيونس اجيت اغسل هنا فكنت انا
بغسل ثلاث ايام في الاسبوع وثلاث ساعات
فالحين لا بنغسل غير يومين وبصراحه بنعاني
بالروحه والجايه يعني وبس ساعتين بنغسل
لدرجه انه اصلا ما تضبط الغسله مش هذا
الوقت اللي احنا بينفع انه نغسل فيه يعني
احنا بدنا اجل شي من ثلاث ساعات اربعه
عشان نطلع السموم اللي في جسمنا فوضع نصبي
بصراحه بعدين بعد امرار بتعب عندي
عفطه حت على صدري لماار لاني ساكنه بعيده
والله كنت انام هنا قبل الحرب انا عشان ما
اروح على
البيت بعدين ابني استشهد ودار
انهدت وين بدي
اروح بدي اروح اعمل خيمه زي ما انا عامله
خيمه على
البحر والحمد لله على عطاه وعلى رضا والله
اول كنا بنجي صلات وصعب في المواصلات كمان
لان بمشي اكثر من كيلو مشي لما نصل
السياره بدي اركب فيها وحين مع الحرب
نحرنا على الزوايده ولقيت باجي الله يكرمك
على كار المنطقه اللي احنا فيها فيها
مواصلات الاطباء هنا يتحدثون عن وضع
ماساوي للغايه داخل هذا القسم بسبب
الاعداد الكبيره التي تاتي لغسيل الكلى
بداخل هذا القسم كان قبل الدوان حوالي 140
الى 160 مريض الان اصبح بعد هذا العدوان
وبعد اعداد النازحين الى حوالي
480 مريض فشل كلوي و والعدد في ازدياد بعد
اغلاق ايضا محافظه خانيونس هناك اعداد
كبير من ما
زال ياتي الى هذا المستشفى ولذلك قمنا
باجراء يعني تقليص فتره غسيل الكلى ل
المرضى بدل ثلاث اربع ساعات الى ساعتين
الى ساعتين ونصف في وضع انساني صعب للغايه
في هذا القسم في مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في
دير البلح يغسل هؤلاء المرضى غسيل الكلى
هنا وبشكل يومي ولكن المطلوب هنا ازدياده
في جلسات غسيل الكلى داخل هذا القسم
المتواضع في
الامكانيات اشرف ابو عمره الجزيره دير
البلح وسط قطاع غزه